[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN ANDERSON: So one
thing right at the start,
I'm not here to sell you NoOps
or even Google as your SRE.
This is based on my
and other's experience
running services at Google
and with conversations
with longtime App
Engine customers.
Great DevOps engineers--
or SREs, if you prefer--
provide a lot of leverage
for moving your engineering
organization forward
with continuous delivery
and accelerating your ability
to reliably deliver changes.
If you don't have anyone
actively doing the DevOps role,
your most experienced
developers end up
getting pulled into the
firefighting effort involved
in running your system.
So one way or
another, you're going
to end up doing ops and DevOps.
Well, you may not
end up doing DevOps.
You may end up just
doing operations.
We'll talk a little bit about
the difference in a moment.
So every software system
that has customers
is going to need care and
feeding and maintenance.
And experienced
DevOps practitioners
understand how to do
that more efficiently.
So DevOps are great.
I'm not saying throw
them out the window.
I'm not saying, don't have them.
I'm saying, let's
make them even better.
Common ratio for DevOps to
feature software engineers
is something on the order
of five, maybe 10, to one.
For some reason that I'll
talk about in this talk,
App Engine covers a lot
of your DevOps basics
for free, letting you spend
more time in your application.
That means your DevOps engineers
can get more stuff done.
They can move your
organization faster.
Or if you want,
your DevOps talent
can also spend some time
improving your application
and writing feature code, rather
than chasing around and putting
out fires and fixing
your infrastructure,
because your infrastructure
will be beautiful and sparkling.
I've spent nine of the last
12 years on call at Google.
Half of that was in SRE.
The other half was as a
developer, supporting systems
that I had written that
were not yet accepted
by SRE because they were
new and not critical enough.
If you went to Ben Treynor's
fireside chat earlier,
he and Ben [INAUDIBLE] talked
about how at Google, SRE teams
come in and focus on the
services that are already
important and make them better.
And it's not a given that
you have an SRE team at all.
That's a little different
than some other organizations.
And App Engine incorporates
a lot of the stuff
that I've learned about
running reliable services--
it's one of the things
that attracted me
to working on App Engine--
for scaling both to millions
of queries per second
and running hundreds of services
with a single small team.
Switching to App
Engine isn't going
to double your productivity.
I don't think I
could promise you
anything that would do that.
But it can give you a
measurable improvement
in how much time you spend
on feature development,
rather than on the operation
stuff that has to get done.
Since we're talking about
spending time on development,
I'm going to talk first about
why you might be spending
a lot of time on operations.
So Google SRE has a
concept called toil.
And toil is work that
you do need to do today.
It'll come back tomorrow, and
you'll have to do it again.
It's not optional.
You need it, in order to
keep your service running.
Additionally, toil
doesn't necessarily
require a lot of judgment
or creative problem solving.
But it has to be done
right, or your system
will be down or broken or slow.
You might recognize
some of these sorts
of things as maintenance
operation procedures
or other best practices document
for handling various issues
that come up with the service.
Now MOPs can be a good
idea for operations
that happen infrequently,
like a manual database
failover, if you do that
once or twice a year.
But if you're using the
same MOP once or twice
a week, that's probably toil.
And you should be looking at
automating it, rather than just
streamlining the
work that people do.
And the antidote to toil
like this is automation.
So if you can recognize
and understand
what needs to happen,
you can find ways
to write software that works
around or solves the problem
so that humans can get back
to being creative, thinking,
coding, designing,
listening to customers,
instead of fighting
your infrastructure.
Now there's a whole lot of
data center automation software
out there already.
We never talked about
what makes App Engine so
useful and special.
I'm going to start
by talking about some
of the other options for data
center automation software.
So at the base of
the stack, we have
what I call fleet
management solutions.
These solutions are
targeted managing a fleet--
hundreds, tens, thousands--
of individual heterogeneous
servers.
They're all
different, or there's
enough differences between them
that you need to pay attention
to those differences.
They may be running
on physical hardware.
on virtual hardware.
It might be a mix.
Oftentimes, you're signing
workloads to individual servers
statically.
A single server is
for a single workload.
And you don't necessarily
automatically scale.
Or if you automatically
scale, it's
a little bit of
a manual process,
using something like a
managed instance group or--
I forget what the
Amazon equivalent is--
load balanced group.
There is a lot of code
in these fleet management
tools for rolling out and
managing operating system
and library level patches,
because every machine
is different.
It has its own kernel.
It has its own
installed libraries.
Maybe some of them are RedHat.
Maybe some of them are Debian.
Maybe you've got some
SunOS there or Windows.
And in addition to
all of that, it also
rolls out your application
code and manages it.
But that's just one of several
jobs that it's got to do.
Now the great thing
about these things
is they're really adaptable.
They're really flexible.
And they let you automate
your software deployments
to your VMs and your
physical machines.
And with the
integration work, you
can implement health
checking and monitoring
repairs and things like that.
So that's actually pretty
good in terms of replacing
a lot of your toil.
The next level of
abstraction, that you probably
heard about a lot
at this conference,
is container orchestration.
So at this layer of
the stack, you're
using something like
Kubernetes or Mesos or Docker.
And you don't worry so much
about managing the base
layer of operating systems.
That's all unified
and pretty abstract.
And instead, you're managing
resource provisioning
by describing your application
in terms of the resource
requirements it has--
how much RAM, how much CPU, what
network ports, what storage you
need.
And then the orchestration
layer assigns those resources
to physical or virtual
nodes automatically
and can perform failover and
pooling and resource grouping.
So resource assignment container
orchestration can be fairly
dynamic and can react to those
failures or the load changes
by rebalancing the cluster,
maybe even moving a workload
from one machine to another
because you've discovered that
one machine is overloaded, which
is great and introduces a whole
host of new needs that you
never realized you had,
like service discovery-- you
need to keep track of where
everything's running--
and clear abstraction
boundaries between systems,
because you need to actually
deploy and scale them
differently.
So moving up in
the stack this way
frees you from a lot of the OS
patch management and deployment
toil, because you can describe
things in a high level.
And it can give you resource
efficiency gains by bin
packing multiple containers
onto the same physical node
without managing individual
VMs and operating systems.
Additionally, because resources
are aggregated in this way,
this can also actually simplify
your hardware build-out,
because you can have
a more uniform fleet
and have the software be
responsible for bin packing
things onto smaller
machines as needed.
And so containers
are a great tool.
And container
orchestration definitely
simplifies packaging
and resource sharing.
But I'm here to talk about
another layer above that that
removes even more toil and
gives you even more efficiency
benefits and takes
your application
management to the next level.
So App Engine is one example
of a platform as a service.
Platform as a
service is designed
to understand and cater to a
particular type of application.
So you can see here, we've
got App Engine and Heroku
and Cloud Foundry that are
all in a similar business
of handling stateless
web services.
But things like Lambda
and Cloud Functions
are another platform
as a service that's
targeting a slightly different
market where web services
aren't really their core thing.
It's, run a little piece of
code and spin up and down
very quickly in a
server-less environment.
And then you can
see Dataflow as well
is another platform for
handling your data processing.
You wouldn't use it to
serve a web application.
But it's a great way to
organize your data management
and your ETL pipelines.
Stateless web
services, which is what
I'm going to focus on
for the rest of the talk,
covers a lot of ground, from
static or dynamic websites
to APIs and shim APIs,
which can aggregate content
from a number of
different back ends
and provide a seamless
content feed to mobile clients
or to other API consumers.
Stateless web services, while
they cover a lot of ground,
they also have a lot
of things in common.
So that gives us the ability
to provide out-of-the-box
experiences that you'd have to
do a lot of integration on some
of the lower layers to get.
So I'll show you an example
in just a moment of what
the full setup would look like.
But there's a recipe
out there that's
pretty easy to find to
scale an application using
those fleet
management solutions.
It involves Nagios
monitoring, triggering
Chef to do a deployment
based on high CPU usage.
So you find your
Nagios instance.
You put some stuff in there.
It has to coordinate with
some stuff that's in Chef.
And you own all those
integration pieces.
App Engine provides
these as scaling knobs
on your application
without needing
for you to explicitly say,
hey, here's my monitoring rule,
and that means do this,
in terms of deploying
another application node.
App Engine knows how to do that,
because you're a stateless web
service.
And because your app is
driven by HTTP requests,
we can also give you automatic
latency and request load
monitoring.
We can also trace your
log statements back
to the particular URL handler
and highlight problem areas
in your application.
These are some of the
tools that internally we
build in SRE at Google.
And by providing this
platform as a service,
we can build them for
you in a scalable way,
as opposed to a bunch of one-off
things for individual services.
So this is an example
of how you could
build your own comparable
platform to some of the stuff
that I've talked about
that App Engine does.
There's actually
a few more things
that I didn't feel
like putting in here,
because there's already a lot of
stuff around your application.
So we'd start with
your application.
You start developing.
Let's say you're using Java
and you're using Jetty.
It's great on your desktop.
But when you want
to go to production,
you'll need to set up auto
scaling and multiple copies
of your application.
And then you'll
need to put a load
balancer in front like Nginx.
And then to debug
your application,
you'll set up the ELK stack.
So now you've got Elasticsearch
and Logstash, and Kibana
that you're running, in addition
to your application in Nginx.
You can still have
Nagios for monitoring.
So now you've got
some visibility
into what's going on.
And maybe Nagios is monitoring
your ELK stack, as well as
Nginx in your application.
And you're getting
all these metrics.
And then you discover
that you're suddenly
running 30 machines.
And so why don't we
go and take SaltStack
and use that to actually
organize and manage
your roll outs?
Congratulations.
Now you've got 31 machines.
And furthermore, I've given
you one set of examples here.
Why don't you replace
Nginx with Envoy?
Or there's a bunch of
different log solutions.
So when you put all the
combinations together,
there's probably 100 different
ways to build this same system.
Is everyone in your organization
making the same choices
for these?
Are you building ELK
over here, and you're
using Splunk over there?
Standardizing on
one set of solutions
makes it a lot easier
for people to move
from one part of the
organization to another
and understand what
tools are available.
Platform as a service is
one way of standardizing
that set of tools so that
everyone has a common baseline
that they're working from.
And they don't need to
learn a new stack of systems
when they go to switch projects.
So assuming that you're buying
what I've got to say so far
and that you're interested in
how App Engine fits into this,
I'm going to explain a little
bit about how App Engine is
organized before I dive
into some of the recipes
and features.
You don't need to
know this stuff
to start using App Engine.
And I've met people who've
spent years building
monolithic applications--
perfectly happy with App
Engine and don't necessarily
understand or worry
about all of this stuff.
But if you're looking to
grow and organize a team
and scale out your
team more efficiently,
it can be useful to understand
how applications and services
and versions all fit together.
So App Engine subdivides
each project--
which in App Engine, we
call it the top level
of an application--
into independent services
which can be pushed and scaled
separately.
So you can think of
services like microservices
that each do a separate thing.
Your microservices can be very
small and have a single URL.
Your microservices
can be not so micro
and can be your entire
application if you want.
Each service, in
turn, is made up
of a set of deployed versions.
So you do a deployment.
And that creates a new version.
And at the service
level, you can
choose to shift traffic forward
and backwards between versions.
So one of the things
that you're deciding
when you split your
application up into services
is, which things should
be pushed together?
Which things should
be pushed separately?
If you have three API
endpoints that all
touch the same database and
need to use the same schema,
maybe that's all in one service.
If you have another
endpoint that
only talks to videos
and cloud storage,
maybe that should be
a separate service.
Maybe you'd rather have
it all be bundled together
because that's easier for you
to manage in your CI system.
That's up to you.
Within each version,
App Engine automatically
creates and destroys instances
of each version in response
to load.
So every time you write
code on App Engine,
you're writing code
for horizontal scaling
automatically.
And we can expand one version
to be running on thousands
of nodes or scale it down
to zero on standard or one
on the flexible
environment if it's not
receiving much traffic.
So moving on from the
high level theory,
I'm going to show you some
examples of how App Engine lets
you run your services
faster and smoother
and apply less DevOps effort
to keeping everything running.
Some of you may have
seen this before
if you're into SRE-type topics.
This is Dickerson's
hierarchy of reliability.
Reliability is one of the
main goals of DevOps--
reliability of delivery,
reliability of the service,
in terms of uptime, reliability
of process in making sure
that things are repeatable.
And this hierarchy was
proposed by Mikey Dickerson who
was the architect of the
healthcare.gov rescue
and a former Google SRE.
I actually worked
with Mikey in Ads SRE.
And this formulation,
based on his experience,
makes a lot of sense to me.
And it's based on Maslow's
Hierarchy of Needs
if you're a psychology person.
If you haven't seen his
talk on healthcare.gov,
there are several
versions on YouTube.
And it's really
interesting to hear
how he was able to go
into a very broken system
and find ways to bring
that up the hierarchy
and introduce stability
and reliability
into the whole process
and integrate SRE story.
App Engine can help reduce
the amount of effort
for getting all of these things.
But I'm going to
particularly focus on
the ones I've
highlighted in blue.
I realize that's a lot of them.
But I thought that
more in-depth would
be a little better than covering
postmortems and development.
So for each of these
layers, I'm going
to be showing you both
the built-in functionality
and some additional
things that you
can do to take them
to the next level
and be more efficient than just
the tools that we ship you.
So starting with monitoring,
I mentioned earlier App Engine
is a platform as a service.
So we already have top level
metrics on your application.
Request latency, requests
per second, queue times,
number of instances, and
all of that sort of thing
can be tracked both across
the application as a whole,
and we can actually also track
things like latency and request
times on specific URLs
if you're interested.
And the best part
is, you don't need
to add explicit
instrumentation into your code.
Since we are offering
you the load balancer,
we can integrate
all that monitoring
into the load balancing layer.
And we integrate that with
Stackdriver monitoring
and inspection.
So you can also export specific
application metrics directly
from your code and align them
with the same metrics that are
coming from your load balancer.
If you don't want a direct
monitoring dependency
in your code--
you're worried about either
the latency or the stability--
you can configure Stackdriver
to export custom metrics
from your logs.
And those can be aligned with
an automatically collected
instance data.
This allows you to
create a single timeline
with business metrics like
conversion rate and code
changes such as
latency improvements.
You can then use the
Stackdriver APIs to aggregate
and export the data and
run a regression analysis
to figure out things like
the effect of latency
on conversion rates.
So putting all your
data in one place
and giving you powerful
APIs to extract it
lets you pull out
more value than you
might if you were putting
everything separately
and you had some things
in Nagios and some things
later on in your ETL pipeline.
Speaking of things
like ETL pipelines,
the stature of a logging API
is really handy for digging
into issues.
The log viewer is good
for getting a quick view
into what's going on.
But exporting logs into
BigQuery is amazing.
How many of you have
used BigQuery before?
You might know what
I'm talking about.
So I can use SQL
queries like this
to dig in and associate error
messages with specific URLs
for a specific
customer, even if I'm
getting hundreds or thousands
of requests per second
and I have half a
million customers.
I had this one customer
issue and they say,
this stuff all seems to
be wonky, but replies
are particularly bad.
So I can dig in and
find out, that's true,
but they're not doing
very many replies.
I can also potentially dig
in and get the stack traces.
I can get any other info
or warning error messages.
And you can really
pull out a lot of data
by putting things
in BigQuery and then
using SQL to extract out the
information you really need.
As an additional
monitoring tool,
Stackdriver Trace is pretty
cool for investigating
the calls made by a particular
request or your back end
connections.
And it's automatically
enabled on Standard,
so you can just try it out
and see what it tells you.
And on Flex or
on-premise, there's
a library that you can
link in that will give you
the same information.
And I believe it also integrates
with some open source tracing
tools.
I don't remember that name.
So incident
response-- everyone's
favorite thing to do.
But when things go
wrong, you really
want to get things
back working ASAP.
You've got that visceral "my
customers are angry at me"
feeling.
As an SRE, I had to write a lot
of postmortems that basically
concluded, rollback would
have fixed this hours earlier
than pushing new code.
So by now, my first instinct
whenever I get a page--
and I am on call, not right
now, but for the App Engine
Management API, I am on
that on call rotation--
my first instinct is
to find what changed
and roll it back, even if I
don't see any correlation,
and see if things get better
while I go and dig in further.
So App Engine, because we
have those multiple deployed
versions, gives you a
quick way to roll back
to earlier versions.
It's a single action.
It takes less than
10 seconds to do.
And there's also
an audit log so you
can see what's actually
been changed recently,
which helps you figure out which
thing you should roll back.
So as I mentioned,
my team actually
builds the Management APIs.
And we talked, when we were
building the traffic splitting
controls, about building an app
that just lets you roll back.
And you can see that my
UX skills are probably
not the ones you'd
want building this.
So fortunately, we have a
Cloud Console mobile app
that already lets you do this.
So don't worry.
You won't have to
suffer through my UI.
Now obviously, roll back is
not going to fix everything.
And there are some failures
that App Engine will never
fix for you.
But if you look at postmortems
in your organization,
you'll probably find something
similar to Google, which
is that code and configuration
pushes are one of the largest
sources of outages.
It makes sense.
You're deliberately
changing something.
You think you know
what you're doing.
Well, you knew what you
were doing 90% of the time.
And the other 10%
doesn't go so well.
But you tested the
common happy case.
So roll back solves
those problems.
It doesn't solve
backend services down.
user data corruption.
Roll back sometimes
will help you there
by changing your
query pattern back
to what it was before or not
corrupting any more user data.
But you'll still have
to fix those yourself.
And it's still up to you
to make the decisions
as to when to roll back and how
to use the tools to fix things.
And if you're using App
Engine consistently,
the other benefit is that
all your tools look the same.
And so your most experienced
people from one project
can help out with
another project
when everything's on fire.
So outages-- not so much fun.
Pushing code, seeing
your code go live--
a lot more fun.
So test and release--
much better incident management.
Got to do the incident
response, or you
don't have any customers.
But App Engine also has a lot of
tools for testing and releases.
And the multiple versions
is the start of that,
but not the end of the story.
So you can see here in the
production environment,
we're doing a traffic shift
from our current release
to the next release.
And we're canarying it
with 10% of traffic.
So we've got some
confidence that it
doesn't break everything.
But we're not putting all
our users at risk yet.
So if something goes
bad for 1% of our users
on the new version,
it's actually
a 0.1% outage at that moment.
So I've still got three nines.
It's not too bad.
Additionally, you
can see that we
have a test environment
that has a whole bunch
of other versions running.
So everybody can have their own
version for development, which,
my experience has been,
drastically accelerates
things versus hot seating on
one pre-production environment.
So what does App Engine not
cover for testing and release?
Well, you'll still need
to run your own tests.
You'll need to
write them yourself.
And you still need
your own CI system.
And you need to choose
your source release
and start the
deployment yourself.
App Engine has integrations
with tools like Jenkins, Travis,
and CircleCI.
There's a lot of other
systems out there.
A lot of them do have
App Engine integrations.
And I've actually built
my own little toy CI
system at one point,
just to play around
with the management API.
And most of my time
was spent figuring out
how to package up my code,
upload it to Cloud Storage,
and then the actual API call
at the end is pretty simple.
So if you're thinking
about building your own,
it's not too scary.
There's some work
you need to do.
But it's not too scary.
It's also easy to
deploy the same code--
you can see here-- to
the test environment
as to production with a slightly
different configuration.
And I've seen a couple different
patterns for doing this.
One common one is to
have a set of settings
in Data Store or Cloud Storage
or potentially even Cloud SQL
where you connect to an address
that's based on your instance
name or your app
name or something
like that, which tells you
where to find everything else.
The other pattern,
which I slightly prefer,
is to actually define your
configuration settings in code
and use a configuration
class which you select
which one of these to use.
And the benefit of that is
that all your configuration
changes end up in source
control automatically.
You don't wonder, hey, who
changed this data store
setting, or how did this config
file get uploaded to GCS?
So I'm going to show you an
example of how that works.
So you can see here, I defined
the base configuration class.
That could be development
environment settings.
That could just be--
in this case, it's none.
If you're using a base config,
you're probably doing it wrong.
You should be getting
one of the other ones.
And it makes it more obvious
when something goes wrong.
Then you can say, I defined
a production configuration.
And then this magic
config basically
chooses one of the
other configuration
classes and extracts
values from it if there
isn't an overriding
environment variable setting.
And then you can see
my top level config
object is an eval that
picks one of these classes
and defaults to development
so that if someone forgets
to actually define the
environment variable,
they don't start running
against production.
Referencing this
in source control,
you can get code reviews
up when you're doing it.
You can actually
test your values
and make sure that you don't
end up with conflicting values
as your configuration
gets more complex.
And also, when you can
make configuration changes,
you can roll them out with
traffic splitting, the same way
that you roll out
your code changes.
Adding a new backend,
maybe you typo-ed it wrong.
It's good to have that be a slow
process rather than a Big Bang
switch over.
So far, we talked about the
basics of app development.
But not that we've talked about
keep your head above water,
capacity planning is
one of those things
that you always want to
get to in the future.
But App Engine actually
lets you get to it never.
And that's OK, because App
Engine has automatic scaling.
It will scale down
to zero, and it
will scale out to thousands
of instances automatically.
And you don't need to
do capacity planning
and reservations
and decide, am I
going to need this capacity
for one year or three years,
or even do I need to
request a quota increase?
App Engine can
automatically scale
for spiky events with low
latency past 20,000 QPS.
And for small spikes--
of course, small is
somewhat relative--
you don't even need
to contact Google.
If you're thinking about
launching the next Pokemon Go,
we might like a heads-up.
But if you're not
launching Pokemon Go
and you're launching something
that's just going a little bit
viral, then shouldn't need
to talk to Google at all.
So as I mentioned,
the Standard run
time, support scale
to zero, which
makes standard runtimes great
for keeping around development
tools and dashboards and stuff
that's not used all the time.
But every so often, you want
to be able to pull it out
and you want it to be
running immediately.
Standard is also much faster
for deployment than Flex.
So if you're trying to iterate
on your development cycle,
you may find that deploying
to Standard is faster.
The Flex environment
requires a VM
to be running in
order to collect
all of the metrics
needed for scaling
and to determine how much
load and so forth is going on.
But you can stop the versions
that you're not using
and stop getting
billed for them.
So we have a lot
of customers who
are using App Engine with
things like Datastore
or a Bigtable who scale out very
wide on their App Engine side.
And if you're using
something like Cloud SQL,
you'll have to provision
your Cloud SQL instances.
So if you can use a
horizontally scalable system
for your storage, you might
not have to do any capacity
planning at all.
Still have to do
budget planning.
I'd run some demos for you.
I wish I had done budget
planning beforehand.
So Cloud Console,
which you can see here,
and the Stackdriver UI,
which I'll show you later,
cover a lot of the
basic user experience
for managing your app.
And another thing to
note is the Cloud Console
is building on
Google's public APIs.
So you can also extract all
this data to your own consoles
if you're building your
own view of the world.
So before I talk
in more detail, I
wanted to highlight a couple
of the cool things we've
got built in.
On the left hand side, you
can see the Cloud Trace
suggestions.
It's automatically identified
several issues with Datastore.
You probably can't see it here.
But it says, use of offset
and data store queries,
which is an anti-pattern,
because when you use an offset,
Datastore still has to read
through the first things.
It just throws them way to
hand you the next stuff.
Use query cursors instead.
Many successive data
store put and get calls.
So by doing these
separately, my app
is paying a latency
penalty each time
I do a put or a get, whereas if
I did multiple at the same time
or parallelized
them, I would have
much lower latency overall.
Because we understand
your architecture
and how your backend RPCs relate
to your frontend URL requests,
we can actually determine that
things like the consecutive put
and get calls are coming from
the same handler, as opposed
to different handlers that
happen to have similar timing.
And so we can suggest these
sorts of improvements.
On the right hand
side, you can see
the error reporting has picked
up a bunch of 500's that we've
served to customers
over the last day
and highlighted particular
issues that we should probably
be looking at and fixing.
Again, this is stuff that
we've automatically built in.
So you could obviously run
this stuff yourself and go
through the logs yourself.
But we've already given
you a basic version that
will often meet your needs.
But sometimes you
know your workflow
better than what we do.
And so I'm going to talk
a little bit about how
you can make an even
better UX for you
for your team that maybe
isn't the same as the UX
that the next would build.
So with all these APIs,
there's lots of great ways
that you can integrate them
together-- some of them mostly
using Cloud Platform
technologies, some
of them using just
a few, but using
some common patterns to make
it easier to debug production.
And the other thing
is, of course,
if you find these
useful, do them.
If you don't-- if that sounds
like a terrible idea to you--
there's nothing that says
everyone must do things
the same way in production.
Your team should be consistent.
But you don't have to be
consistent with the team
in another company.
So for us, we have
a mailing list
for recent push
announcements and status
updates about production.
In our push
instructions, we used
to have a line that said,
send mail to the mailing
list about the push.
There's two problems with this.
The first one is that the
instruction didn't actually
tell you what to say.
So every person had to
interpret that individually.
And the second one was that
a person had to do this.
And it wasn't just a robot
automatically sending
something like a summary or
hey, this push has started.
So a lot of you probably use
Slack or IRC rather than email
for keeping track of what's
going on in production.
You can automatically
update Slack
when there are production
changes, such as traffic
splits, version deployments,
or permission changes,
by setting up a logs
filter on the audit log
and using that to publish just
those audit logs to Pub/Sub.
So you can say, just
users added to a ACL,
or just traffic splits,
or new versions in traffic
splits but don't tell me
about deleting versions.
And Cloud Functions can pull
things off of that queue
and automatically update
a Slack topic telling you
everything that's going on in
production that you care about.
And then all the rest
of the stuff, you
don't have to go and
look at the audit log.
It's already in the
tool that you're already
looking at every day.
You probably also track which
commits fix a particular issue.
But if you've run production
systems for a while,
there's a difference
between the fix is committed
to source control and the fix is
actually running in production.
It's a very important
distinction.
And sometimes when
you have to roll back,
you want to know, what's going
to break when I roll back?
So if you have a consistent way
of tracking which CLs are going
into a particular release
and naming your releases
in a way that's
coherent, you can
update your Jira
or whatever you're
using for issue tracking
to indicate which
things will be broken
when you roll back
to a particular version.
And so roll back is great.
But sometimes there
is a bad thing that
will happen at the same time.
So you need to do some
mitigating steps or something
like that.
And this gives you some
operational awareness
of exactly what's going on.
And this last integration
is a really cool one
that I've seen some
teams build at Google.
But everyone seems to have
to build their own solution.
And a lot of this is because
what makes a release really bad
is not universal.
For some people,
error rate increase.
For some people, it's latency.
You may have other metrics.
But you can have a
Stackdriver alert--
assuming you can describe
what makes a bad release,
you can have a
Stackdriver alert that
detects if there's a problem
like an error rate increase
and sends a web hook or an SNS
notification to your control
stack to automatically
roll back that release
before a human even
has to get involved.
You may still want to tell a
human that this is happening.
And you may even
want to page them.
And if you're building
such a system,
you probably also want a Dead
Man switch so that you're not
fighting the automation if
the release needs to go out
or you really need to
make some other changes.
So I've talked a
whole bunch of talk
about ways that you can
make things more efficient.
Now I'm going to do a demo,
because my understanding is
that demos are
part of the reason
that people come and
watch this stuff--
see whether the demo
burst into flames or not.
So I'm not to show how you can
take off-the-shelf software not
designed for App Engine
and run it on App Engine
and get some of those
App Engine benefits.
In particular, I'm going to use
Jira, which is a closed source
issue and project tracker.
Typically, you run
it on a singleton VM.
And since it's closed
source, I really--
oh, don't-- OK, you
can cut over now.
But I still have a little bit
more to talk about before--
definitely don't cut over now.
I actually have a
couple more slides, too.
So I can't really make
any software changes
to the Jira software
itself to make
it run better on App Engine.
I do use the flex
environment here.
But I thought that it would
be interesting to show you
a real application being
put on App Engine that
wasn't designed that way.
And Jira seemed like, hey,
this is something that probably
a lot of you have seen or used.
So my architecture
looks pretty simple.
My developers talk to Jira.
Running it on App Engine.
I'm using Cloud SQL as
the backend database,
because I'm doing this
to not managed servers.
So I'm not going to set up
my own server, my own Oracle
or Postgres or
something like that.
I'm going to use
what Google has.
And I'm using Flex,
because I'm going
to need to run a
little additional code
inside the Docker container
that's not the main web
application process.
And one of the great things
about the Flex environment,
if you're trying to do
something like this,
is that in addition
to Java and Node
and PHP and all those
other lovely runtimes,
Flex can run raw
Docker containers.
So I start with a container
that's built on the Google Java
runtime, and then I
do a bunch of work
to install Jira into MySQL
connector and so forth.
I set it to be on
the correct port.
And then you can see that I
copy in a wrapper script that
does all the fixes I
need and a core database
config, although that wrapper
actually takes an environment
variable and puts it into
the DD config at runtime
so that I can change which Cloud
SQL instance I'm talking to.
So one interesting
feature of Jira
is that it's got this
database for all your issues.
But it actually also builds
a local on-disk Lecene index
in order to be able
to search all of them.
So that's kind of a big
stateful local cache.
And we're talking about
stateless web services.
Fortunately, Jira has
a re-indexing API.
So I can use that at
start up and periodically
after that, re-index
my database, in order
to get Jira to actually have
Search working, and do things,
like which issues are assigned
to me, actually shows up.
I also use basic scaling
or manual scaling
to keep exactly one instance
running per version so
that there's less chance of
updates going to one server
and then needing to call
re-index on another.
If you were scaling
out Jira really large,
that might be a problem.
Most of the time, if
you're getting five QPS
to your Jira instance,
something's probably wrong.
So now if you
could switch over--
so I'm running this
off of my Chromebook
since that's my primary
development machine.
But this means that I
need someplace where
I can run the raw VM commands.
So my typical pattern is to spin
up a worker VM in the project
that I'm using.
And it makes it really
easy to install tools
for demos and things like that.
It also means that I won't
have any fancy pretty editors.
And instead, I'll be mostly
using tools like VI and less.
Here we go.
We have SSH.
Let's see.
Can everyone read that?
OK.
So before this talk, I actually
built a new Jira image based
on the fresh out-of-the-oven
latest 732 release from March
1.
It was great that they
shipped a release,
because that meant that
I wasn't just installing
the same software again, because
I started working on this demo
long before they shipped it.
So you can see in the Container
Registry I have a base
image and a Jira 732 image.
Now I'm going to go back.
And here is my command line.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about what this is doing.
I don't need help either.
So I'm deploying a
version named 732
based on this Jira
image and an app.yaml
that I have in the
same directory.
The app.yaml looks
pretty simple.
So I say it's a custom
runtime running on Flex.
I give it an instance
tag, just in case I
needed special firewall rules.
It turns out, I don't.
I assign two CPUs
and two gigs of RAM.
I turn of health
checks, because Jira
doesn't know to answer 200 at
the App Engine health check
URL.
So I just say, don't
worry about that.
And I have Stackdriver
monitoring do that instead.
And you can see at
the bottom, I've
set manual scaling
to one instance
So that I don't end up
with multiple copies,
each with their own
big, fat, local cache.
The last two flags say,
whichever version's
running now, don't stop that.
The default for Flex, to
save money and confusion,
is that your old
versions are shut down
when you deploy a new version
so that you don't end up
paying for half dozen in
VMs as you're developing.
The no promote flag says, I'm
deploying this new version,
but please don't
make it live yet.
I'll show you later on in
the demo how we make it live.
Obviously, if you
don't say no promote,
we could just have it happen
as soon as it's ready.
So as I mentioned,
the Flex environment
can take a few minutes
to start the VMs,
configure the load
balancing, and so forth.
And Jira also
takes a few minutes
to start from a fresh install.
So while that's happening,
I'm going to show you--
I'm going to say "yes,"
because otherwise, we
would not get any further.
And now I am going to show
you what we have running.
So you can see we've got Jira.
It looks pretty normal.
If I log in, you
can see, oh, look,
I've got a bunch of
issues assigned to me,
which is how I'm going
to keep track of what
stuff I'm supposed to show you.
So we're going to start by
showing off the logs explorer.
Some of you have probably
already seen this.
So this is from the
last time I ran it.
By default, this will
show you the standard out
and standard error plus
the Nginx server that's
in front of your application.
But you can also pull
in things like VM events
or the SIS log from the VM.
And let's get the
whole pile of stuff.
You can see that we just have
a new audit log event here
that says that we are starting.
The operation will tell
us that the operation ID
and then in the
proto payload, it
will tell you this
is an audit log
and that this is
called by service data.
It was down off the
front of the screen.
This was a Create
Version request.
And here is all the
information about the versions.
You can see it's Flex.
It's running on VM, manual
scaling, and some other stuff
that we set.
Here's our environment variable.
So let's go back.
OK.
So we've talked a little
bit about the logs explorer.
So next thing I'm
going to talk about
is how to add log
metrics for data.
So we've got this re-indexing
piece that I'm doing.
Let's take a look and
see how we can actually
keep track of how often
we're calling re-index,
and is that working the
way we would expect.
So this is the log based
metric section of Stackdriver.
You can see it's right
next to the log viewer.
And in both cases, you can
use this Create Metric link
to create a new
metric that matches
a pattern on your application.
And this is the currently
running version.
And you can see
there's a lot of--
well, here's a kernel
message from the kernel
that's booting up.
But there's also a
lot of health checks
and some Docker information
and stuff like that.
So I am actually going
to show you the--
I've already
created this metric.
And you can see, if
we go in and edit it,
that it's actually a query
against the logs API.
You can use this
same type of query
to export stuff to
BigQuery or to Pub/Sub.
And you can see that here
we're looking at standard out
and standard error
message that says,
re-indexing is 100% complete.
And we have a bunch of
these messages from 9:00 PM
and from last night when
I was working on it.
So that's how you
set up these metrics.
Let's take a look at what you
can do with them after you've
set them up.
I've added them to the
Stackdriver dashboard.
There's no data over
the last one hour.
But if we look
over the last day,
we can see that I
started some VMs.
And they did re-indexes
at that time.
You can also see
the request rate
and that I was messing around
a bunch with the GR instance
earlier today and
that at one point,
the latency was really high.
But all the rest of
the time, it was low.
And here's our CPU usage.
And it looks like we're
really not using two CPUs.
And probably one would
have been sufficient.
So we figured out a little bit
about how to use log metrics.
And now I'm going to talk about
the two different interfaces
that you've got for looking
at how your app works.
So one of them is the
standard Cloud Console.
standard Cloud Console where
you can see the basic graphs.
And there is a
pull-down where you
can see information for a
particular version and then
things like CPU utilization
and latency and so forth.
The other option is to build a
Stackdriver custom dashboard.
The advantage of the
custom dashboards
is that you can put
together lots of your data
into one place.
And you can put together
different dashboards
for specific issues.
So maybe sometimes you
have CPU usage go crazy.
Maybe you're exporting the
number of backend database
connections, and that goes wild.
You can have
different dashboards
for different purposes.
So let's see how that
deployment is going.
So the deployment is finished.
I'm going to go
back over to Jira.
And you can see that right
now we are running 731.
So if we go over to App Engine
and look at the versions that
are available, we have 732.
We have one called Base.
And let's not use
this one called Bad.
This is an old habit.
The Migrate Traffic button
is actually a better choice.
But I'm going to send
100% of the traffic
to the new instance.
If this was a public site, I'd
probably start at 5% or 10%.
This is an internal
tool, so I'm just
going to swing all the
traffic over to the new site.
And now let's see
what happens if we--
I don't know how much
of this gets cached.
So we're going to
reload the page.
And it's going to ask me to
log in again, because it's
a new Jira instance, and it
has a different cookie cache.
And the LastPass is
not going to help me.
And so you can see we're back
on the same page we were before.
But now we are running 732.
So that's the end of my demo.
And when you're ready, you
can switch back to the other.
That's the end of my talk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]